[Music]
earlier this month a man named patrick
leoyea was shot and killed by a police
officer after he was pulled over for
allegedly driving with an unregistered
license plate he ran the police chased
him there was a struggle and an officer
shot the unarmed man in the back of the
head while he was face down on the
ground
it's hard to even say that out loud now
when we hear that story most of us ask
what is wrong with our country when an
unregistered license plate gets you the
death penalty but there's another
question out there one that gets asked a
lot after police shootings
why didn't he just comply
so tonight let's talk about that in a
segment called how did we get here
[Music]
[Applause]
police shootings are one of those things
you need to talk about even though you
don't really want to like prostate
health or the fact that mamma mia is
really just a musical episode of mori
white privilege is having three men who
might be your baby daddy and still
somehow getting played by meryl streep
so tonight we're not going to go into
the details of the latest horrific
police shooting instead we'll step back
and talk about a bigger question why
don't black people just comply with the
police now there are a million reasons
why a person might not comply in any
given situation but we are only going to
focus on two okay the first is easy when
black people encounter the police
they're often terrified if you're a
black person in america you've seen a
million viral videos of black people
being murdered by the police so when you
see the police even if you've done
nothing wrong you can feel like you are
in danger and when you're in danger you
want to get out of danger which is why
running can seem like a good option now
it can be hard for some white people to
understand being scared of cops maybe
in your life the police have always been
there to help you and it's hard to
believe that that's not true for
everyone it's like finding out that the
life jacket you use to keep you afloat
is actually a lead vest when put on
someone else and for black people the
different treatment by police isn't just
perception it's reality findings from
new york city's stop and frisk data
shows that compared to white residents
black residents are 17 percent more
likely to experience police use of hands
18 more likely to be pushed into walls
or the ground 24 more likely to have a
weapon pointed at them and 25 more
likely to be pepper sprayed or hit by a
baton so it makes perfect sense that
black people are fearful of police and
you act irrationally when you think
something is going to cause you pain
it's the same reason i scream every time
i see a hot comb ah my ear
and it gets worse according to a 2019
study black men are more than three
times more likely to be killed by police
over the course of their lifetime than
white men so when a black man gets
stopped by police and runs that's
actually pretty rational but if it's
still hard for white people to
understand here's another way to think
about it
what if black people react to police the
same way white people react to black
people
studies have repeatedly shown that white
people perceive black people as more
violent and more likely to commit crimes
even though that's not true in one study
where white participants were shown a
slideshow of random people's faces black
males were seen as more threatening than
white males which is horrible the only
time looking at a face should be
threatening is when you come across a
co-worker on hinge
do you swipe right to be nice do you
swipe left to make it less awkward
neither you quit your job and you leave
the country but the racism doesn't stop
at faces a university of wisconsin study
found that when people consider how
dangerous a neighborhood is they don't
base it on the crime rate they base it
on how much of the population is young
black men
that's right if there are young black
men then it is automatically dangerous
which is insane if that were accurate
the scariest place in america would have
been the set of a different world
and hey feelings are just feelings
except for one tiny thing when white
people feel like they're in danger they
call the police those very same police
who are killing black men at over three
times the rate of white men
white people love calling the cops so
much you would think they'd have a punch
card where the 10th call gets them a
free sandwich and let's be honest maybe
there is a certain kind of white person
that just likes to stir things up
who am i thinking of sophie
girl
you invited all three dads to a weird
island when you could have just sent
them an email and you didn't even tell
your mom girl you don't want a wedding
you want drama
now it's important to note that white
people don't call the police on everyone
one study of a mostly white community in
austin texas found that when residents
saw a suspicious person who was black
they called the police 60 percent of the
time and only 10 percent of the time
when they were white
basically white people decide black
people are dangerous so they call the
cops black people understand the
inherent danger of interacting with cops
so they freak out and when they freak
out the cops decide they're dangerous
it's a cycle of fear that keeps leading
back to
black people getting killed but all this
is just part of the reason why a black
person might not comply with the police
the second part of that is complying
doesn't guarantee your safety since 2015
625 black people were running away from
the police when they were shot and
killed which is terrifying but even
scarier
875 of them weren't the fact is
sometimes running away gets you killed
and sometimes staying still also gets
you killed now i'm a black lady who grew
up in omaha nebraska i do not have the
time to tell you about all my police
run-ins
wait maybe i do
those motherf have pulled a gun on me
multiple times a gun
on this
so the next time someone asks why black
people don't just comply with the police
feel free to tell them exactly how we
got here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you